this is war one protester said it
certainly looks like it in parts of Hong
Kong right now they went on the rampage
in the teenager's hometown venting their
fury 'it is shooting by police by
targeting chinese banks or outlets and
they got applause from those watching
[Applause]
this was a crowd looking to start
trouble much of the city has been
shocked by the shooting the first time a
live round has been fired at a protester
and it's stoped the determination to
keep pressing for change
you're gonna keep on fire
[Music]
so a police station was petrol bombed in
the New Territories the fury at the
police has soared even higher after they
insisted their actions were legal
because lives were in danger in this
extra footage we've retained you see
protesters chasing one policeman holding
his shield before wrestling him to the
ground and eating even so many are
asking why the policeman fired at
point-blank range when he was carrying a
second less lethal weapon in his other
hand one witness who spoke to Sky News
insists there was no warning given when
the protesters were going towards to
police the cops had already raised their
guns even before there was any physical
contact and up to the moment the shot
was fired I didn't hear any warnings the
shooting prompted a range of protests
across the city with the injured
students own school friends demanding
action be taken against the police
whilst demonstrators walked out of their
offices at lunchtime to shut down
several city streets bringing traffic to
a halt but drawing much support from the
watching crowds and in shopping malls
they gathered to sing the newly adopted
national anthem glory to Hong Kong many
with their hands over their heart to
signify support for the shot school boy
by evening there were mass gatherings
demanding the police force be disbanded
even as the Junior Police Officers
Association was demanding they be given
more power
and emergency laws be introduced the
protests have already paralyzed much of
the city for nearly four months now the
shooting has guaranteed the unrest is
going to continue
Alex Crawford Sky News Hong Kong